hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday March 6th 2017 what's going
on everybody I am in Phoenix Arizona
isn't that exciting Phoenix Arizona um
it actually is Matt I'm psyched I'm
working at stand-up live doing two shows
tonight two shows Tuesday two shows
Wednesday I'm you know putting together
my new hour and everything and I got a
bunch of [ __ ] I've actually been
listening to my act I always you know
when I'm putting together a new hour oh
I always record I just never [ __ ]
listen
well now I'm finally listening to my act
I figured it out when I can do it cuz I
threw the [ __ ] months to sit there and
listen to yourself what I'm doing is um
I listen to it on the car ride home you
know if I had a decent set if I had a
shitty set what's the [ __ ] point you
know what I mean it's kind of like if
you're always taping you your team right
but you only watch if they win you know
I know people who do that [ __ ] they like
no what the [ __ ] happens before they
watch and if they lose they just don't
even [ __ ] watch so I've actually been
watching in that type of [ __ ] and
speaking of which your team winning and
losing
ol freckles came in last night and I
went to the Phoenix Suns were playing my
Boston Celtics so I decide you know what
I'm gonna go to that game right my
hundred and 17th
[ __ ] franchise professional home team
I have a professional sports team that
I've seen a home game of one hundred and
[ __ ] seventeen of these [ __ ]
I got 10 more to go I can't get out any
ten every time I get to 10 and I'm like
oh one more team I'll [ __ ] then I'll
have nine left and somebody moves you
know I got down to ten I'm like alright
the next one's gonna get me down to nine
and then the [ __ ] ramp the rams move
back up to 11 right so then I go see the
Thunder and I'm thinking alright look
man I'm down I'm down to [ __ ] I'm down
to nine and I'm like wait a minute
wait a minute I saw the New Jersey Nets
I never saw the Brooklyn Nets oh it's
still 10 so I'm like all right next week
next week when I go see the Suns I'll be
down to 9 teams left right so I'm
sitting there watching the Suns and I'm
like burnsy I'm down to single digits
the fan slam is going down one of the
loneliest accomplishments ever I guess
if you went with a bunch of other people
I got to find the old pictures of me at
these stadiums I swear to god they're
all like disposable camera pictures held
by a stranger you know when I was doing
all these [ __ ] gigs in the middle of
nowhere and [ __ ] and I passed through
the major cities and I would just go to
a goddamn game anyways so last night I'm
thinking I'm going to the Sun Celtics
game I'll have nine teams left and I'm
like wait a minute the [ __ ] charges
just moved to Los Angeles so in a month
I'm working in San Antonio and I'm going
to a Spurs game going to the [ __ ]
Spurs and then I think I'll finally be
down to nine you know god forbid if the
[ __ ] Raiders don't move to Vegas
after that but anyways I went to the
Suns game right so I show up immediately
the club hooked us up with tickets gave
us great take so we sitting two rows
buying the [ __ ] one of one of the OD
call it in basketball one of the nets
one of the goals one of the back boards
right two rows back so it's really three
rows back as they got all the [ __ ]
cameraman you know but still it's like
great seats and I look down on the right
and is this guy just riding the reps in
the first quarter and he really gives a
[ __ ] so I'm looking at virzi and I'm
just looking over go look at this fungus
guy's out of his mind
there's a guy who gives a [ __ ] this is a
hardcore season ticket-holder man but
come on I'm laughing like he's just like
he knows the refs names
he's calling him out and all that [ __ ]
and burrs he starts going he goes I bet
that's the owner I'm like nah yo no
wouldn't be sitting down he would be
yelling like that if he was the owner
and he's like well Mark Cuban rides the
refs like that I had the [ __ ] out of
here so
you know a guy I mean I'm gonna look
this guy up right so we we look him up
and it's the owner I got to tell you
Phoenix Suns dude you guys got a great
[ __ ] owner Roberts Sarver is his name
men we ended up talking to him at the
end of the game because I tweeted a I
was making fun of um what's his face his
shoes who sneak is he [ __ ] wore
sneakers I've ever [ __ ] seen kelly
olynyk the big white goof the 7-foot
[ __ ] pylon out there right I don't
know Celtics love that guy you got so
many goddamn minutes maybe it's a road
trip or whatever but dude this he had
these [ __ ] sneakers on I think Garrow
you premium wore him and that [ __ ]
Super Bowl against the Redskins when he
[ __ ] up the field goal who they were
like they look like black football
cleats from the early 70s the ugliest
[ __ ] things ever seen so of course I
tweet about that's why I so I tweeted
about the thing and I guess the owner's
son was watching he goes oh he's
probably sitting right next to you blah
blah blah that's how I didn't mean the
guy but anyways long story short so I
tweet about this [ __ ] thing's making
fun of the guys sneakers thinking
obviously these have to be the worst
[ __ ] sneakers without a doubt even
with the Internet even with Twitter even
with all of these [ __ ] [ __ ] that are
on social media nobody can argue that
these are the ugliest [ __ ] sneakers
ever right they were low top [ __ ]
field goal kicker cleats on the [ __ ]
early 70s right and all these sneaker
heads alike you mean the Kobe 11s I
guess it's a Kobe Bryant sneaker and and
what because it says Kobe on it all of a
sudden it's the Kobe's do do you mean
the Shaq for teens
I [ __ ] hate sneaker heads but [ __ ]
can't stay at them with the 5000 [ __ ]
pairs of sneakers taking them out of the
box showing them off on MTV Cribs and
licking the sole so it's like
I never will I never even wore these
joints before yeah I can tell from your
[ __ ] man tits you never worn before
this sneakers once you go take a [ __ ]
walk in them Birds he's a big sneaker
head I'll tell you no one is [ __ ]
overrated it's so [ __ ] overrated
Jordans you know what I mean I'm not
saying they're not good-looking some of
them so most of them I [ __ ] ugly as
[ __ ] and dude the [ __ ]
mouth-breathing dopes maybe that's what
it is the amount of [ __ ] out jeez I'm
walking around now I'm walking through
the amount of [ __ ] dopes that wear
Jordans you know what it is about
Jordans it's you don't even have to
[ __ ] think you know what I mean all
you got to do is get a pair of Jordans
you know everybody's gonna like oh yo
are those the sixes are those the jordan
sixes do look at these sixes I got him
with the black with the gold outline yo
these sneakers are crazy right these
things are crazy you know I don't know
he's [ __ ] mouth-breathing morons with
the goddamn sweatpants in their Jordans
you know first he's a big Jordan guy he
loves Jordans he was he's wearing a pair
this week they're [ __ ] ugly as [ __ ]
they're all black and then they got like
this whitewall tire thing done it just
because it says Jordans I'm ago I
published you check out these new George
you like him I go now I actually I don't
and he can't understand he goes with
their Jordans dude these these are
Jordan once it's like - I don't give a
[ __ ] at the Jordan night I'm so sick of
the numbers
dude what's your favorite Jordans you
like the sevens really you like the
seventh now you got to make sure that
that it just says Nike on the back if it
has him on the back then those aren't
the real ones the Kobe 11s
like what do you guys think that if you
[ __ ] put them on you're somehow going
to be able to dunk you're going to score
close to 80 points in a [ __ ] NBA game
because you're wearing Kobe's the sedale
3/7
I don't know I I don't understand if a
[ __ ] snake is ugly it's ugly I don't
give a [ __ ] I cannot [ __ ] but if you
guys you have to go on and you have to
look at a picture of those [ __ ]
sneakers they're like referee sneakers
from the [ __ ] early 80s it's just a
black low top [ __ ] slipper with the
Nike swoosh on it do you mean the Kobe
11 dude the Kobe 11 are [ __ ] crazy -
crazy
Tony you get yourself you get yourself a
[ __ ] tracksuit and you put on a pair
of those dude over oh you go out to the
club people people are are those the
sixes I I just don't understand [ __ ]
basketball sneakers okay some of a good
look and some of them aren't just they
think they drive me up the [ __ ] wall
Paul virzi is the funniest [ __ ] human
being I've ever met in my life like he's
one of these guys like I love him to
death but the [ __ ] that he likes it so
he likes obvious [ __ ]
it'd be like dude you know what I like
you know what I like I like amenities
it's like really dude you like getting
extra [ __ ] extra comforting [ __ ] that's
amazing you know I never really thought
about that I don't know I have to think
about this do I like amenities you know
what I like Paul I like a lack thereof I
like less than like who would ever say
dude you know what you know what do is
there anything better than pizza
is it anything better than a great slice
of pizza dude you know what I like I
like a bologna sandwich dude a bologna
sandwich with white American cheese and
mustard ooh
the mustard puts it over the top it's
crazy it's a joke I mean it's literally
a joke
it just I don't know it's uh check
doesn't even need to be said quest it's
a bologna sandwich yeah it [ __ ] hits
the spot
old mainstream poly dude you know what I
like you know I like I like a golden
retriever do you know it's crazy a white
picket fence um sorry I got to get him
back on this podcast cuz I won't Bartnik
calls him mr. Maksim because everything
he likes it's like it's he likes what
everybody likes but then he sees got
this simplistic [ __ ] great philosophy
will it be like bill but bill what's
wrong what's wrong with sweatpants you
know you can't argue with them I exactly
there's there's nothing wrong with it
it's just you know the conversation is
just like it just doesn't need to be
most of the conversation just doesn't
even need to be had dude is there
anything better than just walking around
in sweat pants dude you put on a pair of
sweatpants with some Jordan threes over
over do what is better than having on a
hoodie and a pair of Kobe 11s you go to
massage parlor and she's jerking your
dick I mean a ditty I mean my crazy it's
it's over it's a joke it's literally
it's a joke all right
I'm sorry [ __ ] all you sneaker heads out
there god bless you with your little
[ __ ] hobby of keeping your sneakers
clean and you know [ __ ] walking on
your heels anytime there's this any sort
of rubbish on the ground groan [ __ ]
man just walking like a goddamn duck on
their heels hey buddy what the [ __ ] I
got on the sevens what is it the first
day of school
do you know what I love you know what I
love is it anything better than when it
snows on Christmas that's the type of
[ __ ] he says it's like no yeah it's
great Paul I think everybody's pretty
much in agreement I think Jewish people
like if it snows on Christmas you know I
mean it probably adds to their Chinese
food I don't wake who the [ __ ] doesn't
like a fresh blanket of snow as long as
it isn't a goddamn store dude you know
what I like amenities is there anything
better than taking a steam I know I mean
you know that's also that is a great
thing that everyone is in agreement with
you know what I like dude I like fresh
air is there anything better than like
non polluted air when you breathe in I
mean it's crazy it's a it's literally
it's a joke um Jesus I went on a [ __ ]
tangent there oh my god after second I
thought the recorder wasn't recording I
forgot my [ __ ] microphone so this
might sound a little bit do t say
anything better than just laying in your
bed and just waking up and doing your
podcast I mean it's a choice literally
it's it's it's a joke
you know I have to look up these [ __ ]
sneakers
how the [ __ ] Kobe Bryant one of the
greatest [ __ ] top what two three
players of all time individual plays
teammate he was a [ __ ] nightmare you
went to that [ __ ] confessional comes
up um Fermi sent it put in my password
here
stupid Laker fans always chant MVP at
the guy I hate that Celtic fans are
chanting MVP at Isiah Thomas by the way
it reminds me of Laker fans that were
always every time [ __ ] Kobe stepped
on the court and did not pass the ball
and scored 40 [ __ ] points and they
lose again and they dab they pay did you
see him dunk on that guy and then they
lost oh my god he's unbelievable
maybe if we get 58 free agents in here
and [ __ ] Phil Jackson that
when a title and VP alright um nobody's
dude he's wearing the Kobe's he's
wearing the Kobe loves I have to look
these [ __ ] sneakers up how ugly these
goddamn things are and the fact that
these [ __ ] sneaker heads you mean the
Kobe's I mean the rap sneakers those
[ __ ] cleats this guy's wearing he
looks like [ __ ] Ken Stabler out there
Kobe 11 you cannot tell me that this
[ __ ] the computer doesn't listen to
you oh my those are [ __ ] dancing
slippers Jesus at least he got the best
you got the best color they come in pink
they come in red and white they got a
Miami Dolphin color dude those literally
look like women's sneakers like you
should have liked the low-cut sock with
the little ball on the back if you wear
those [ __ ] things and I'm looking
look at the ones did 112 and $30
I bet this I bet if I went on YouTube
and this fan I looked up Kobe Elevens I
bet this some [ __ ] [ __ ] sitting
there licking the [ __ ] who was a guy Fat
Joe did that in his MTV Cribs and he had
like chickpeas now she's like the
[ __ ] George sixes and then he licked
the bottom um it's like dude do you
realize the sweatshop that those things
were [ __ ] Maidan and you think those
things didn't hit the ground in there
and God knows they probably don't like
they probably ate those people go to the
bathroom at the [ __ ] station and
you're gonna lick the bottom of those
goddamn sneakers they were in a
hermetically-sealed sneaker box dude
they were in a cardboard box and were
shipped over here from the other side of
the world I think I'll put my tongue on
them alright I look this up I'm gonna
see if I could find that I'm gonna find
a [ __ ] video here Kobe 11 Larry I
don't know why but of the first video
that came up said exploding poo and a
guy had [ __ ] on his face no I didn't
think they did that type of stuff on
[ __ ] Kobe 11 shoes alright and some
[ __ ] gonna do a [ __ ] review Nike
Kobe 11 performance review dude these
are the ugliest [ __ ] sneakers I've
ever seen in my life
these ones are actually worse Kobe
Bryant gives LeBron Jameses autographed
shoes God what the [ __ ] did they talk
about other than winning championships
that'd be like listening to [ __ ]
Superman and like [ __ ] Batman talking
I Kobe gives away shoes to a fan hears I
[ __ ] all over the guy he's like the
nicest guy ever
Kobe helps a busload of sick children
get to the Staples Center by towing it
with his own body and his Kobe 11s all
right maybe I was wrong um Nike Kobe I
gotta get off this [ __ ] subject what
am i listening to some guy do a [ __ ]
review of the sneakers Nike Kobe 11
performance overview my initial thoughts
I [ __ ] love YouTube who gives up I
guess you guys are listen to my thoughts
but I'm just being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyways let's get back to the goddamn
game alright so Kelly olynyk's out there
and his kobe 11 suit they were [ __ ]
crazy dude you get a 7-foot white guy in
Kobe Elevens it so it's all I mean the
black guys are still going to go right
around them and have their nuts in his
face when they dunk on but I mean his
feet from the ankles down it's it's it's
over it's gonna be a joke it's literally
a joke um all right anyway so we go we
watch this game the owner of the Suns is
a [ __ ] riot totally I'm just watching
him ride in the referees like old school
guy you know right down there on the
court watching the game and you know
he's not about some luxury box or
anything like that right so anyway so
we're watching the game and the Celtics
come out flat which you knew they were
gonna you knew they were gonna cuz they
just beat the Lakers any time I'm
telling this right now gamblers gamblers
anytime the any Boston team I'd the wide
say the Bruins are the [ __ ] Celtics
going that West Coast trip okay
if you want to make some money bet
against them the day after they play
either the Clippers the kings of the
Lakers because they [ __ ] go to LA and
to the game they all go out they bang a
bunch of [ __ ] broads a bunch of
[ __ ] actresses or whatever the [ __ ]
it is they do and then the next game
when they go to San Jose down to Anaheim
out to Phoenix up to Portland whatever
the [ __ ] they go next there's always a
letdown so the Celtics come out flat the
[ __ ] Suns are all over them I'm lover
the guard was on the Suns was just as
fast it seems as Isaiah so he was right
up on him I'm frustrating the hell out
of I mean Isaiah had I think four fouls
in the first half and so we're watching
the game and I'm just going like I
[ __ ] knew it I'm so excited to
finally see this team I've been watching
seen almost every game of this year and
they come out flat I'm like oh man am I
really going to the [ __ ] hangover
game now what do I give a [ __ ] I got
three [ __ ] tickets but still you know
it's a bunch of Celtics fans there
they're all going [ __ ] nuts and
everything we had like nothing to cheer
about I think we were down by like 10
after the first half and we just start
chipping away chipping away chipping
away first half was ugly I mean it was
like it was like a first quarter score
with like four minutes to go was like 32
it seemed maybe it was like six minutes
to go so at the half I think they're
both in like the 40s I don't even
remember and and I said Paul jokingly I
go you watch they're both gonna score
over 100 they're gonna eat up whatever
so of course they come out everybody
starts hitting their shots it turns into
this great game and then the fourth
quarter comes and we start chipping away
chipping away chipping away we down by
like 10 or 11 then went down by eight
then went down by five and then went on
my for next thing you know we're up by
like two so you guys all know how the
[ __ ] game ends right we [ __ ]
missed what's-his-face Brown missed a
foul Sean Isiah missed a foul shot that
would have [ __ ] iced it and we let
him hang around hang around [ __ ] hang
around the end I came out was tied we
were up by one it all happened so you
know it happened so [ __ ] fast when
you're at the game and you don't have an
announcer holding your hand and you
don't have something that you can
actually look at there's too much [ __ ]
to look at so we
to inbound the [ __ ] ball right this
guy goes around Jae Crowder I think tied
it up we're like [ __ ] right that's right
we were up by two instead of being up by
three and force him to take a three and
they probably would have missed the
[ __ ] thing
that's right the guy goes right around
Crowder lays it in crowds going nuts
there's like four seconds left I go I'm
gonna try to get it to a Isiah Thomas
let's see what happens we [ __ ]
inbound the ball Isiah one of the only
times I've seen a mess up this year
messed up the past he was kind of
looking up court you know because
there's only four seconds left before he
caught the ball they kick it out to this
[ __ ] dude what the hell was his name
actually wrote it down so I would give
him much respect he deserves Tyler Ulis
they kick it out to him and he hits a
[ __ ] 3-pointer at the buzzer to beat
the Celtics nay here's the thing I had
second row [ __ ] seats and guess what
I didn't even see the play it happened
on my end you know why because the
[ __ ] [ __ ] who were in the flivver
in the front [ __ ] row
they inbound the ball and they could see
that you know Thomas was [ __ ] it up
they stand up you're in the front
[ __ ] wrong what are you standing up
for there's nothing in front of you you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and all of a sudden I just
saw the ball go through the net and
everybody go and where'd the horn goes
off everybody goes nuts I go what the
[ __ ] does that count did that just go in
what the [ __ ] just happened I had to go
home
to watch the replay to see what the [ __ ]
happened I was sitting in the second row
I couldn't see cuz he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
stood up in front of me um I don't I
don't understand standing up when
nothing's in your weight they haven't
you ever heard that expression why stand
when you could sit by sit when you can
lay down why stand up when you're in the
front [ __ ] row and what is blocking
your goddamn view anyways alright I'm
done [ __ ] [ __ ] in here I had a I had
a great time and evidently Kobe 11 so
[ __ ] crazy man you know
dude Chris Evert should wear that
[ __ ] sneaker that's what looks that
looks like the one that different
colored ones are like you know do you
know something that is a testament to
how great Kobe Bryant was you know it's
almost like he's so [ __ ] good Nike
was at the factory going like how
[ __ ] ugly do you think we could make
a sneaker if we put your name on it
these people that lick the bottom of the
[ __ ] sneaker will they still buy
these goddamn thing you know what now
that I'm looking at them because I'm an
old man they don't look like you play
basketball great they look comfortable
as hell as far as when they're in a
different color I guess they look like
slippers there's a thing I want to I
want to [ __ ] ask you Kobe had that
horrific Achilles injury I swear to God
which is is like that was the end of
anybody's career that is like the
classic old man basketball injury is you
go to take a step in your [ __ ]
Achilles goes right up the back of your
leg I mean I don't even think I don't
[ __ ] play hoop at all but I still
[ __ ] I'm always stretching my [ __ ]
Achilles I swear to God before I get out
of bed that's I don't know what it is
about that injury I just know like five
or six people that have had it and I
want no part of it I want no [ __ ] you
you never walk right again I mean Lee if
you got Kobe's money you know you can go
to Germany and meet the grandsons of the
Nazi [ __ ] doctors and they'll spin
your [ __ ] blood in a centrifuge
whatever the [ __ ] they do and then you
come back and you can still dunk or
whatever you know but most people don't
have Kobe money so what's going to
happen is is you're going to go down to
the veterinarian down the street and
he's going to sew that thing bang and
you're never going to you're never going
to be you know that's it god help you if
you're ever in a situation where there's
panic and the crowd starts running and
it's a stampede and you've blown out
your Achilles at some point in your life
that's you're going to get trampled you
know
you're going to be that zebra in the
Serengeti that gets eaten by the [ __ ]
alligators basically what's going to
happen um but you know he has the low
tops I wonder that probably had nothing
to do with it I'm just surprised guys
wearing low top [ __ ] sneakers again
like it's uh is it you know I don't pay
attention this [ __ ] I usually watch
hockey right and first he's going like
no no no Kobe kind of brought the low
tops back everybody's wearing so I
looked out on the court and I saw a
number of people with low top so people
still had like these high-top sneakers
on but the amount of ones like that that
they were like velcro you know like a
little kid he can't tie his sneakers yep
they had like velcro high tops with like
a [ __ ] belt around your ankle and I
was I don't know I don't know about
those either
you know what's hilarious how arrogant I
am that I actually think that the world
cares what a 48 year old white guy
thinks about [ __ ] sneakers well why
don't you just get a pair of shell toes
um so anyways we went to the goddamn
game and we a great [ __ ] time
Roberts Sarver and his family are great
we met we met him briefly just talk to
him just great people like that guy dude
if I was a Phoenix fit I would be very
happy with that guy as an owner even
though I know you guys are rebuilding
that guy [ __ ] loves his team there's
a lot of owners they don't give a [ __ ]
you know they own a team so they can
have hookers and blow up in a [ __ ]
sweet dude that guy he was it looked
like he I was going to say it's like he
had money on the game and he does he's
paying the [ __ ] players um anyways um
all right so let's plow ahead here um I
should probably read some goddamn
advertising right here alright loot
crate Oh give me the loot hmm
be the envy of your friends be the envy
of your friends why would you want your
friends to be envious gee I wish I had
what you had and get 100% exclusive
crates at loot crate calm / / and enter
my code bird to save $3 off any new
subscription wait until I tell you about
Marches crate it's wild
all capital letters why it's wild on a
quest for epic gear house house whiz and
collectibles loot crate has it loot
crate offers an epic range of
pop-culture items for less than $20 a
month if you're more of a fan fanatical
fashionista I hate that [ __ ]
fanatical fashionista then try loot
where monthly wearables and accessories
and coke classics and your favorite
franchise now with your coke classics
and your favorite franchises whoops
fanatical fashion he said what the [ __ ]
does that mean
offer expires March 19th at 9 p.m. that
roar in the distance is a call will you
answer it this month we're going primal
and unleashing the Beast of some of pop
culture's most ferocious franchises they
love alliteration with the F's it's
[ __ ] fantastic
this March experience iconic items from
overwatch Wolverine Jurassic world and
predator including as always our monthly
t-shirt and pin go to loot crate com
slash burn enter my code bur to save $3
off on any new subscription today hey
nerds I don't know what the [ __ ] that I
don't know what that is
do you guys have a dent Lee love it and
you're buying this [ __ ] because they
keep advertising on my podcast I know
what predator is I know Wolverine is
that's when that Australian guy has to
eat a whole [ __ ] chicken everyday to
get jacked and I was reading the other
day that guy he's played Wolverine eight
times and he has to pack on like 25
pounds of [ __ ] muscle he goes I eat a
whole chicken every day goes my jaw is
literally sore from eating it's like why
don't you just do roids you know it's
like they test you as an actor did you
hear about the [ __ ] Wolverine a can't
make any more movies he got suspended
for three movies he did steroids me
undies oh boo boo boo me undies be
undies watching the Phoenix Suns but
doot doot me undies me undies Atlantic
is a [ __ ] bum he's [ __ ] seven feet
I don't give a [ __ ]
he's got the lateral movement of a
[ __ ] dump truck I don't know what
this anyways your balls will feel nice
and [ __ ] soft when you wearing the
Kobe 11s they're [ __ ] ugly um meet me
undies the lateral movement of a dump
truck I know it doesn't whatever it
[ __ ] rhymes you can at least give me
that me undies use one of the following
openers in your read okay elevate your
underwear game to the next level with me
undies you've perfected your wardrobe
but what about this stuff not everybody
gets to see if you've been settling it
dude is there anything better than a new
pair of underwear I mean it's crazy your
balls are alive
you know dude you haven't a new pair of
underwear and and you have the olynyk
sevens on I'm telling you dude
and you go is there anything better than
a bowl of [ __ ] great nuts great nuts
right you [ __ ] you your nuts are
[ __ ] comfortable your great nuts of
because are soft you touch it's gonna be
a great day you put on your sweatpants
you get a slice of pizza you know
somebody says something you go oh if
you've been selling for store-bought
underwear five packs I have something
that will change your life for the
better me undies what's the first thing
you put on and the last thing you take
off its your underwear make your most
important piece of clothing the best it
can be with me undies what is beyond
ease oh just seriously soft and feel
good undies delivered right to your door
me under you've be fun ease up kelly
olynyk actually hears this and kicks me
in my red nuts with this [ __ ] Kobe
11s that would really be justice there's
your lateral movement your plenty of
balls is going this way the others go on
the other way you know something that's
why I think you have a ball bag you know
I mean because it hurts so much to get
kicked in the balls God had to give you
balls the opportunity to try to get out
of the way you know me it's like a
running back that knows how to take a
hit you know you can't have like like
Earl Campbell just running straight up
and down you can end up in a [ __ ]
wheelchair
you know what I mean I know Jim Brown
doesn't like it but these running backs
that step out of bounds they prolong
your career that's what your balls are
doing in your ball back all right back
to the copy here me undies are designed
in LA oh Jesus and made from sustainably
sourced micro modal Modell are it's a
fabric three times softer than cotton
evidently me undies softer than Sox lugs
on these isn't that supposed to be
luxury l uxe lose a undies come in and
ever-changing selection of classic
colors maybe you can find some to match
your Jordan sixes dude is there anything
better than walking around in your
underwear and you find some Jordan
sevens that match
I mean it's [ __ ] crazy if you're
wearing a bathrobe and you're smoking a
cigar I mean it dude it's over it's a
choice literally a joke we undo softer
than saw is there anything better than
free porn bold shades and advertising
adventurous patterns so you can tailor
your undies to your own personal style
and guess what you can save time and
money each month with the monthly
subscription and if you're not ready for
a subscription that's okay you can still
save that's because my undies is
offering you 20% off your first pair
just use our special URL the undies
dot-com slash bird and get 20% off your
first pair so go ahead revamp your
underwear drawer you deserve it once
again that's me undies com / / me undies
com / / oh jesus here we go oh my god
Dollar Shave Club everybody you know
what I'm gonna read one more of these
because I got three left I'm gonna take
a break you know what I mean I can't be
[ __ ] reading all these goddamn ads
Dollar Shave Club dude there's no reason
to use a cheap disposable [ __ ] razor
okay ridiculously high prices kid for
some gimmicky [ __ ] thing that's got a
laser pointer with 17 blades make the
smart choice make the Marcus choice make
the smarter choice and join Dollar Shave
Club before Dollar Shave Club
it was either save money and get a
painful shape from a disposed
disposables like the one they give away
for free
the gym which felt like shaving with the
piece of glass or you pay a fortune for
the latest gimmicky shave breakthrough
you don't need like a laser chin
detector or 17 more blades
yeah dude the only two blades one blade
stopped all right it's one of my ladies
shaving my legs so here two blades was
the [ __ ] three and three blades and on
[ __ ] horrific it just got too big he
couldn't get underneath your nose and I
got a cute little button nose it even I
had a problem you know I can't imagine
somebody with one of them Roman noses
you know one of those gladiator noses
Mediterranean I can't say the obvious
choice here because everybody would get
offended but you know what I mean I'm
those poor people what they've been
through can you imagine that all of a
sudden there's this [ __ ] three blades
I mean does the suffering ever end get
it get a close smooth shave every time
and you can't beat the convenience or
the price of the club if you haven't
tried Dollar Shave Club yet you're
missing out the [ __ ] is this I set my
alarm for 8:00 a.m. why would I do that
oh I know why I got to pick up the
rental car I forgot I had to do my
podcast but I just woke up like a
goddamn machine knowing wait a minute I
got to do my podcast get a close shave
just clothes smooth shave every time and
you can't beat the convenience of the
price if you haven't tried Dollar Shave
Club yet you're missing out it's an
amazing shave and an affordable price
there's no smart choice in the market
and right now they're giving away what
one-month trial for any of their raises
for a dollar with free shipping after
that it's just a few bucks a month
there's no long term commitments no
hidden fees and you can cancel whatever
you want get your $1 trial at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / all right okay
here we go here we go here we go let's
get back to the [ __ ] podcast so I've
been listening to a bunch of [ __ ] old
school country not all the way back to
Hank Williams but like that outlaw [ __ ]
you know right before the outlaw [ __ ]
it's George Jones Considered
law I don't know but listening to him
led obviously to all of these other
[ __ ] guys right and I ended up listen
I remember that this song do you guys
remember Johnny paycheck Johnny paycheck
was this country singer and he I swear
to god he had a hit song called take
this job and shove it and it was such a
[ __ ] hit it's so struck a chord with
people that they actually turned it into
a movie there was actually a movie
called take this job and shove it it was
just it was about a [ __ ] guy who was
working in a job that he hated and he
wanted to tell him you know basically
tell him to go [ __ ] themselves but he
didn't have the nerve and I think was
because the lyric was someday I'm going
to get the nerve to say it and everybody
could relate to it being like hey I also
hate my [ __ ] life and I want to make
a change but I don't know how to do it
you know what I mean it's like the whole
Donald Trump [ __ ] phenomenon not the
informed people you know what I mean I'm
talking about the the mouth breather you
know I mean like with Hillary Clinton
you had the informed person that wanted
to vote for her and then you had the
hissy fit [ __ ] dope this will be
great for women like your life was
really gonna [ __ ] change um I swear
to God I just don't I don't I don't
understand adults who haven't [ __ ]
figured it out yet that you're you're on
your own
okay playtime is over nobody cares about
you okay I don't care what color their
[ __ ] tire their bra is they don't the
level of money that you have to have and
then you have to give it to these people
to for you to even be on their radar you
have to be going to these ten thousand a
hundred thousand fifty thousand dollar
[ __ ] plate dinners with them and you
have to stand in a line of people that
all paid that money okay and you got to
get up there with your [ __ ]
shapeshifter [ __ ] lizard eyeballs and
you got to try to peer into their soul
I didn't think you talked to him you
just walk up with a napkin that says how
much money you're going to give to him
and then you're on their [ __ ] radar
has nothing to do with your genitalia
anyways so all the ugly so I'm getting
off the rails here so this [ __ ] guy
Johnny paycheck he's got this [ __ ]
show so I'll take this job and shove it
it's the funniest [ __ ] just there's
no way to listen this song and not
[ __ ] just speak I played it for Paul
Bercy he was crying laughing he goes
this can't be a real song I go - not
only is a real song I was turned into a
movie just the way he says shove it his
voice drops way down he goes take this
job and shove it ain't working here no
more my woman done left took all the
reasons I was working for these are the
actual lyrics you better not try to
stand in my way
cuz I'm walking out the door you could
take this job and shove it
I ain't working here no more than this
stupid bass line comes on boo boo doo
doo doo doo doo doo and he gets all like
kind of quiet you know what a redneck
gets quiet you know and starts talking
leans in it's [ __ ] scary you know
non-white ease even for white people
that's [ __ ] scary there is nothing
scarier than a redneck leaning in at a
bar thinking that you we're all in the
same team that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] cuz
you're a me like I don't want to do I
don't I don't want any part of what
you're about ready to tell me sir and I
want to try to get out of this
conversation gracefully how do I
dismount out of this [ __ ]
conversation that the second they went
on a [ __ ] redneck looks the opposite
way of the conversation and then leans
in I'm telling you this should be like a
[ __ ] an injector seat on your bar
stool to get you the [ __ ] out of where'd
it go did I get left behind so I swear
to God so when he gets into the verse
right he it's like he's leaning in I've
been working in this Factory for now on
the
fifteen years all is time I watch my
woman drowning in a pool of Tears you
know and I what I love about all those
old school country songs is that [ __ ]
women always leave they're always crying
or whatever but these [ __ ] [ __ ]
they never say why and whenever I listen
to these songs it's just like dude what
the [ __ ] were you doing
I get it you're working at this factory
you don't like the job
why is your woman drowning in a pool of
Tears what the I mean are you taking
this [ __ ] so you don't have the balls
to try to get a better job tell your
boss to [ __ ] off so what happens you
come home you take it out on your wife
is that what you're doing I vent [ __ ]
jobs I've had low pay for the first
[ __ ] I don't how many years of being
a comedian was a low paying job I never
had a girlfriend
drowning in a pool of Tears I mean I
definitely made him cry but that's cuz I
was an [ __ ] had nothing to do with my
[ __ ] I wouldn't blame my job
I've been featuring on the road for now
on 16 years part of these days anyways
you got you just listen to the [ __ ]
song you got to hear this song you got
any dumb Johnny paycheck I know I'm
making fun of him but I actually I don't
know there's something about this I
listen to this [ __ ] song it just
gives me all kinds of ideas for
characters and [ __ ] like that in movies
and whatever but I haven't downloaded
George Jones George Jones Tammy Wynette
all of these [ __ ] people and I swear
to god you gotta you gotta listen to
George Jones these days these days I
barely get by is inadvertently one of
the funniest [ __ ] songs you're ever
going to listen to your life do you have
one of those friends that just calls up
in complaints all the time and you try
to help them out and go hey but what if
you do now I can't do that well blood
the [ __ ] guy who's just resigned
himself yeah alright with my what this
would X Y & Z would happen if so I can't
with that [ __ ] attitude that's
exactly what's going to happen
you know what I mean I got a couple
friends like that way after a while you
just like to you're a white guy in the
United States of America how far down
the [ __ ] track before the race starts
do you have to be jesus [ __ ] christ
how the [ __ ] are you complaining um
complaining I'm not saying that white
people should not complain okay I know
there's a lot of people drowning in a
pool of Tears part of these days I'm
going to get them I'm gonna blow my top
it's like dude why don't you just
address the fact that you don't like
your job apply from some other jobs if
you don't have the training take some
night courses you know get the training
you need instead of sitting there
seething coming home taking it out on
your [ __ ] woman George Jones has
another [ __ ] song called the Grand
Tour I listen to I'm telling you gotta
listen to these [ __ ] songs right I
listened that song it's like George what
in the [ __ ] did you do to your woman
it's like step right up come on in if
you'd want to take the Grand Tour of
lonely house that once was home sweet
home you're like Jesus Christ and this
[ __ ] he goes through his whole
house over there is the chair where
she'd bring the pipe or to me and sit
down on my knee and whisper oh I love
you hey you like Jesus Christ right
there you want to get out of the house
this [ __ ] won't stop straight
ahead is the bed where we lay mom
someplace
when he gets all the way to the nursery
you're like oh Jesus Christ
and he goes she took the [ __ ] baby
and the key thing in all of this is he
says there's a rings and of things and
it's like this [ __ ] woman left all of
her stuff and took the baby George what
the [ __ ] did you do to him this woman
didn't leave you she fled the [ __ ]
scene did some sort of detail you you're
not [ __ ] giving me here we're in the
empty booze bottles I mean what I
actually listened to that song I feel
bad for the woman in his life until I
found out she left then I actually feel
good yeah get the [ __ ] out it and get
that kid out of that tell me anything
I'm supposed to feel bad for you
sounds like you went out back to chop
some wood and she just crashed she saw
some daylight somehow got the chains off
around her [ __ ] ankles grab the kid
and get the [ __ ] out of there um anyways
this recently there's gonna be some pure
country fancy like you missing the point
man take this job and shove it ain't
working here the more allright
ProFlowers everybody woman done left me
my woman done left me hey Johnny
paycheck come on it's just you and me
well what did she what what'd you do you
know I imagine if she [ __ ] around on
you you would have mentioned it
alright maybe I'm taking these [ __ ]
songs a little too seriously um I have a
problem with that like when I listen to
rap music
you know like who Suzette new group that
everybody migos when I when I watch
their videos and [ __ ] and they're coming
up in those supercars and they hold the
[ __ ] money out it just it literally I
have to look in the other direction it
just drives me not seeing artists doing
that I just I'm always thinking in my
head please please buy some real estate
please don't blow it all on [ __ ] coke
Elevens oh my god dude watch an artist
watching people who don't understand
money I guess but I would say artist you
know the [ __ ] that we [ __ ] do it's
just the dumbest you know it's another
stupid [ __ ] thing I love these people
that buy watches that are like you it's
like do that thing you could hang that
on the [ __ ] wall I'd know what time
it was from across the room why do you
have that on that root on your wrist the
amount of guys that like my height in my
size
walking around with a watch that only
would look right unlike a [ __ ]
offensive lineman is it's it's like did
you take that out of a submarine is is
that like deep-sea scuba diving [ __ ] so
you can you can go [ __ ] go down to
like what 9,000 feet without the goddamn
dial won't bust on it
I got me a bagel watch people in a
different time zone could tell what time
it is take this watch and shove it
alright ProFlowers everybody have you
ever forgotten your anniversary if
you're not nodding yes you're lying
Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] is this I
don't forget my anniversary it get
dumped dumb not gonna lie T it
definitely sneaks up on me well I'll be
off buckets in two days what can I get
her what can I get him I don't have time
maybe I'll get a some [ __ ] flowers you
know those people that are just hard to
shop for like your wife for your
anniversary or your sister for a
birthday it's just the worst trying to
find that gift hey you don't know you
don't know I think that's supposed to
say what you don't know what they'll
like and be what it's just the worst
trying to okay it's just the worst
trying to find a gift at a you know
they'll like and be won't cost an arm
and a leg well I'm going to make it easy
for you ProFlowers is my go-to for
flowers is actually a flower store down
the street that's my [ __ ] go to I
hate the Internet
you know I'll go on there and I'll try
to click on something and next thing you
know Ali they either walk the order
either won't go through all I'll have
enough [ __ ] funeral to read them
enough funeral I'll have enough [ __ ]
flowers to Ribery Elvis that's what I
was trying to say there I just started
picturing his funeral anyways ProFlowers
is my go-to for flowers they're fresh
price right and a perfect gift for
literally anyone oh yeah get one for
your guy friends
that's a [ __ ] hilarious gift you just
want to freak out one of your [ __ ]
friends just get us some flowers and
have a car just say thinking of you and
then you're right in parentheses smile
and they get delivered straight to your
recipients store how easy is that right
now go to ProFlowers right now
ProFlowers has a special gift offer just
for our listeners get $10 off your
purchases for 29 dollars or more 10
bucks off for any purchase of $29 or
more Pro flower bouquets or bouquets
police or police are guaranteed fresh
for 7 days or your money back
they have seven step quality check which
means the flowers are always awesome
your website is super easy to use you
can schedule your delivery ahead of time
for any date you want and get you get
back to your day ProFlowers is a
no-brainer gift for a birthday and an
anniversary every occasion or even for
no occasion at all any time when you
want to keep want her to feel special
they if you don't want you woman a woman
done left me so I've got some pro
flowers playing at home in her [ __ ] they
take care of all the details do yourself
a favor and help out the show by
supporting ProFlowers I know I know you
have either a birthday or your
anniversary coming up well everybody
does if you wait long enough so right
now get $10 $10 off your purchases for
$29 or more at ProFlowers but this deal
definitely won't last long just go to
proflowers.com and enter the code burr
at checkout to get this special deal I
was wondering why they were gonna be
advertising flowers this time of year I
was like what are gonna get it to [ __ ]
East get some Ash Wednesday flowers why
they advertise
because you know what they probably had
their maximum appeal they probably hit
their maximum [ __ ] and I just realized
it's probably somebody sleeping on the
other side I mean I'm waking them up
with my [ __ ] Johnny paychecks singing
make it over here anyways so they're
probably like well how can we get people
to [ __ ] buy flowers all year round
how can we create a need well
everybody's got an anniversary
everybody's got a birth dirt birthday
right hey I like the way you're thinking
Karl we can sell flowers to whole year
round
all right stamps calm everybody avoid
the hassle man of the post office and
mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages domestic or
international create your stamps account
in minutes online with no equipment to
lease no long term commitments with no
no equipment to lease and no long term
commitments click print mail and you're
done unlike the post office stamps com
never closes print postage for lettuce
or packages at your convenience 24/7
seven days a week
stamps.com brings all the surfaces
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer Stan's comm will
help you decide the best class of mail
on your needs no need to lease an
expensive postage meter I use stamps com
any time I got posters you know I'm
going to [ __ ] myself out after shows
which I haven't done in a minute but I'm
you know I'm thinking I'm gonna start
[ __ ] doing that again now that I'm a
father now that I got my daughter my
daughter don't left me took gold reason
okay right now you too can enjoy the
stamps service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without a long-term
commitment go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bird that stamps comm enter
BRR alright I'm getting up against it
here you know what I'm doing today by
the way
I'm gonna go see Oakley OTO I'm gonna
see my dog Cleo
the people that ended up rest getting
her from us live out here so um I'm
actually gonna get to see our visitor
today and tomorrow and I can't wait to
see her and everything she's probably
not even gonna give a [ __ ] because she's
probably be so in love with the other
people because I kind of realized that
gunwale she was in love with the people
that had her before us and within a week
she [ __ ] loved us I mean dogs just
they adapt they just [ __ ] a damn so I
got another five minutes here and then I
got to take off so I got time for like
one question here let me see let me get
let me get a good one here all right he
rightie a dictator bill I'm 19 years old
and I've been with my girlfriend Wilma
Dolan left with my girlfriend now for
two years I know what you're thinking
too young for all these silly problems
that's not what I'm thinking I'm
thinking good for you way to go way to
go fella anyway for the first year of
our relationship literally everything
was perfect I still love her just as
much as I did then I'm sure she loves me
just as much however during the second
year of our relationship relationship an
overnight shift changed and then we
stopped having sex it base it's
basically non-existent and now and again
every couple of months it will happen
but I know she's not enjoying it this is
because she was on the implant
contraception injection at first I was
questioning myself and if it was me that
wasn't getting her in the mood anymore
but she promises me that it isn't
because of the implant
she says it's that it what the [ __ ] is a
contraception injection
Jesus I I mean I've never heard of that
[ __ ] it's an injection so you won't get
pregnant dude if you literally told me
contraception actually meant it's gonna
get you pregnant I would believe that
too let's make one of those [ __ ]
words that I just ignored my whole life
you know like soliloquy like what the
[ __ ] does that mean you know
contraception implant official site get
the facts [ __ ] that I don't want facts I
want pictures images okay they're
showing it that it's nice and small
there's some reason they keep putting it
up against their bicep they stick it in
your [ __ ] arm
what
looks like some [ __ ] robot [ __ ] okay
its birth control implant they stick a
[ __ ] toothpick in your arm and then
you can't have a baby I don't get it
anyways
oh yeah that's probably [ __ ] annoying
to have it in there you know what I mean
she goes to hug you in the inside of her
arm hurts anyways after the first I was
quest my son blah blah she says that it
that has caused her to completely lose
her sex drive she says she just had it
removed and it's been a few weeks since
and nothing has changed yet I feel so
much resentment towards her every day
and what I can only describe as
depression as soon as I see her most of
the time I find myself being such an
angry short-tempered person now when
normally I'm usually happy and smiling
at Jesus might be time to get out of
this relationship buddy but you know
something if it really affected her like
that it depends on how long she had it
in then maybe she needs longer than two
weeks but you know if you're gonna be an
angry lunatic I mean if you don't leave
eventually she's gonna but you know what
you get yourself a song on it a woman
MacDonald a toothpick in her arm now she
won't suck my dick one of these days I'm
gonna whip it out and wipe it on the
wall you can take my dick and shove it
um right in your [ __ ] mouth you [ __ ]
but doo doo doo dee but do you do you
okay I always try I always seem to try
and hide my need for sex and act like I
don't ever want it and tried to show
disinterest but I never can I guess it
just must be more important to me than
it is to her I never thought sex was
such a big deal but the last year has
taught me that when there's bad sex life
in a relationship it can really cause
the whole thing to just break down it
just got to the point now that I've said
we need some space and a break because
the last thing I want is to ruin our
relationship um dude you're [ __ ]
miserable man and you have to you have
to you know it's you got to be with
somebody and like understand them and
you know be there when they're going
through a tough time but like you know
if they're not understanding how [ __ ]
miserable you are you're just gonna you
just going to keep getting more
miserable and then
you know then they're gonna be miserable
and then in the end they get a [ __ ]
break up with you and you can be like
what the [ __ ] I should have done that to
them much easier breaking up with
somebody it's not something you should
do to them it's something you should do
for yourself alright this is a deal dude
you're not [ __ ] happy all right
you're not happy it's great that you
take in a [ __ ] break and I would go
out and I'd [ __ ] go try to enjoy
myself and meet somebody that doesn't
have a [ __ ] toothpick in their arm
that doesn't want to touch my dick you
know I mean that's just getting down to
brass tacks here that's what's going on
right they stuck that [ __ ] in her and
now you can't stick your [ __ ] in hurt so
I mean why you got to get the [ __ ] out I
get out you're young don't you nineteen
what are you to marry her what are you
in the military people in the military
getting married when they're 19 you know
a woman dawn left that's what you do
it's just sounds like you sound like you
need like a long time away from each
other the way that was read dude that
sounded like a [ __ ] 40 year old guy
wrote that in your 19 so that's kind of
a good sign that maybe she get the [ __ ]
out who knows but I would not say
anything mean I would not and I just you
know you want to be able to see the
person again and not get a glass to the
head you know what I mean that's kind of
what you're going for so the art form is
you just tell them how you're feeling
you know I'm just not happy I'm sorry
that's just how I feel I'm just not
happy and I'm finding myself less and
less happy and it's affecting my moods
everything you just said and I'm finding
that I'm getting angry and I don't want
to be angry around you and create any
misery in your life so as much as this
is going to hurt you I'm walking out the
door you can take this relationship
shove it that's it then walk out the
door you know and you'll probably walk
out that door and you'll be sad a little
bit and you'll walk a little more and
you start skipping and then you're
running down the street your head
you know might be one of those breakups
or come either one huh why did I do it I
don't [ __ ] know but you're 19 you
know if you got the whole you got your
whole [ __ ] life ahead of you
you don't need being this this sounds
like you're [ __ ] married I'd get out
all right that's it okay that's the
[ __ ] podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves
I will check in on you on on Thursday
and that's it I'll let you know how she
no CLE over the next couple of days is
which is gonna be [ __ ] awesome and
it's also you know what I'm just like
that you know we got a cool family and
uh you know I think I'll come out to
Phoenix a couple times a year you know
do a run a shows like I'm doing here go
to a game or something like that I'll
hang with the dog it's kind of nice you
know all right that's it I'll talk to
you guys on Thursday